hi I'm Aquafina I'm Jack Black and we're
doing the wide autocomplete interview
[Music]
love you here we go
does Jack Black sing yes I do
[Music]
does Jack Black have a band I do
tenacious d tenacious d man tenacious d
time you've got you know like a destiny
does Jack Black actually play guitar I
do play guitar but I don't do any of the
solos I stick to the power chords I play
with passion I play with ferocity what's
your favorite chord the D chord okay did
Jack Black sing welcome to the jungle in
Jumanji no I didn't but I sang it on the
set of Jumanji a lot a lot actually what
he said to me the first my first day on
set yeah I do is Jack Black a nice guy
yes yes yes I'm glad you said that
because that was not for me it's I'm
nice he's one of the nicest guys I've
ever met it's a pleasure to be around
is that black actor vegan no but I would
like to be I am in spirit and really
it's time for everyone to consider that
lifestyle why for the environment sure
it turns out I found out that vegans are
better for the environment why cow farts
next okay this is me can't aquafina sing
well she's not gonna give us a sample
she's got Betty Davis I dug up music are
you she got better - I'm okay
can't aquafina play PMS yes I know my
way around the old black and whites you
tickle the ivories that ticularly having
give a little you know a little
afternoon delight you know what's like
the hardest song you learned nothing
because I never really learned it but
but you know what I can do I can I can
pump out chords and I can and I know
where C is alright yeah can Aquafina fly
mm-hmm you know I used to get a lot of
airplane anxiety but now it's just you
know I go with it you know I get on the
plane maybe I'll maybe I'll have some
vino you know so you're not like
Travolta though you didn't get a fly a
pilot's license no you know that the
Travolta is famously like an actual
pilot and he flies his own big jumbo jet
blue dude where he lives he has like a
runway he flies literally out of his
backyard
look who's talking - so that actually
makes sense
did not see that you didn't see - I
barely saw number one when did aquafina
grow up grow up when did i was a I was a
90s baby say are you a Generation Y
millennial you're a millennial
where does Aquafina live you know
nowhere and everywhere wouldn't you like
to know okay ready
what's Jack Black Jack Black's real name
Thomas Jacob black what's Jack Black's
first movie Bob Roberts Bob Roberts what
is Jack Black's favorite food I know
this one
I'm gonna guess you asked on gone guys
oh you're right cheeseburger
cheeseburger cheeseburger five four
three burger I'm going
what is Jack Black's religion Judaism
born and raised Judaism but my father
converted he was a Protestant and then
he kind of went back so now I'm I'm kind
of a daywalker I got a little bit of
both Hanukkah and Christmas nice I just
got Christmas all you got is Christmas I
remember all my my my Jewish friend used
to be like we got seven days yeah of
Christmas you know yeah but what's up
with that song on the seventh day
appears mesmerized like 12 days of
Christmas in that song there's just the
one so why did I say on the twelfth day
of Christmas in that song I think for a
while
what's Jack Black's nationality born in
the US of A but I have a little bit of
Polish a little bit of Scotch Irish hmm
a little bit of Russian mm-hmm a little
bit I can't remember the other one what
is Jack wax favorite color I like it a
green blue
I like blue green is my favorite mission
account
aquafina what no no school did Aquafina
go to I went to PS 196 and then I went
to Halsey which was JHS 157 and then I
went to LaGuardia High School for the
Performing Arts and then I went to SUNY
Albany dan you went to a lot of schools
yeah dude what has Aquafina been in oh
my god IMDB it yeah going to the next
one you don't have to say what does
Aquafina do I just pretty much sit there
you're an entertainer extraordinaire
what languages just Aquafina speak I
speak I'm actually fluent in English and
I speak a little Chinese and a little
bit of espanol and I can say OOP when
was Jack Black born August 28th 1969
very go
Virgo like a month before the lunar
landing 69 a good year dude I've always
been proud to be born in 69 I've never
wanted to be born in any other year it
just seems like the raddest year to be
born cuz you're from the 60s which
everyone knows is the raddest decade but
not too early and this is like just
caught the tail end yeah one man called
we were born on June 9th because it
would have been six nine six nine that
would have been hard when did Jack black
start acting Jack Black started acting
in like 1982 was my first professional
gig
I got a commercial when I was a little
kid for strangely enough a video game
called pitfall a jungle like it was very
similar to Jumanji
what is Jack Black phone number
wouldn't you like to know it's all sixes
and nines but we won't tell you the
actual combination why is Jack black
called Gables my partner in Tenacious D
is Kyle Gass I called him cagey and then
I wanted to call him cage for sure cuz I
didn't want to say cagey I was a cage
and then he was like I don't like don't
call me cage
I'm gonna call you Jay but short for JB
JB I was like good call me Jay and then
he started calling me Clark Gable's and
then it was just Jay Bose why is Jack
black called Jablonski well it came from
Clark Gable's and in Jay bowls and then
Jablonski I guess it was just a
celebration of my polish roots Canadian
no I'm not Canadian is Aquafina named
after Aquafina for legal purposes no and
I do not intend hereby from this moment
to sell duplicate or her
or vend water is Aquafina related to kim
jong yeah he's my biological father oh
my god
he was my body was my father in crazy
rich Asians and and I called him Papa
FINA because that's what he is aquafina
is Nora from caline's
yeah that's the name of my new show
coming out where did Jack Black grow up
Hermosa Beach California when where did
Jack Black go to high school I went to
Culver junior high then I went to a
little school called Poseidon that
doesn't exist anymore and then I ended
up at crossroads where I met my wife my
future wife Wow how did Jack Black and
Kyle Gass meet Kyle Gass and I were in a
theater company in Los Angeles called
the actors gang we were both into music
and he was a great guitar player and I
wanted to learn guitar and I asked him
to teach me guitar and thus was born
tenacious d that's awesome true origin
story of the deep how did Jack Black and
Dave Grohl me so me and Kyle had this
band Tenacious D and we were playing
little gigs around town we're playing
the Viper Room and we're behind a little
curtain and who pops his head in it's
Dave Grohl he goes I'm Dave Grohl just
wanted to say have a great shot we'll
watch your show and we're like and then
we had a great show and then we talked
to him afterwards and we became friends
and that's that's the story that's
awesome where did Jack Black go to
college I went to UCLA I was not a good
student though I slept through a lot of
lectures and I was really good in
theater I was a theater major and I ran
away with the actors gang theater
company and like my second year of
college and I didn't tell my dad for
like a year and a half
because I knew he really wanted me to
get a degree didn't want to disappoint
yeah but he's forgiven me over time
where does Jack Black live in Los
Angeles let's leave it at that
it's a big city 9100 Rosa BMS Road no I
just made that up I hope there's no FINA
dad who was Aquafina dad Wally were
missing some s's big Debs
aquafina who is she you know I'm a
Gemini I like long walks on the beach I
have a size 5 and a Jew who was Aquafina
[Music]
kinky I can I can actually honestly say
that I cannot tell you that yet who does
aquafina sound like dude but look how it
yeah okay upside down it was really
freaking me out
I thought I said so Ned yeah you know
you you know I sound like I sound like
an angry man mandrill that's that's what
I said that's my default tone yeah it's
it's a lot of bass last but not least
who is Aquafina sauce yeah yep
well done all right should we just do
the cards over again and take the top
it's really Swiss a case those things
back on yeah good rehearsal yeah
[Music]